we're in the
galaxy de bataille and if anyone thought
that
war in europe belonged to history
for the last two weeks we've seen that
the choice by
russia under president putin was to
bring war back to europe in the face of
this and the unheard of violence
of russia against ukraine and its
population is a tragic turning point for
our
history we're all aware of the fact that
it's a turning point as well for our
societies for our peoples and for our
european project
for the last two weeks our response
ladies and gentlemen this has just been
said we've responded through unity
rapidity and a spirit of responsibility
choices were made very quickly
all 27 with our institutions and
coordinated with all of our partners
in the context of nato and g7
diplomatic workers made it possible to
isolate russia israelia recently at the
general assembly of the united nations
for two weeks now ukrainian men and
women have been fighting courageously to
defend their freedom their democracy
their sovereignty and the integrity of
their land
europeans have a clear position
unanimous
and firm condemnation of the russian
aggression
at all international levels and we've
grown full consequences of this
in trailer with the resolution that was
adopted the general assembly
support to ukraine together we've agreed
to deliver
hardware not just humanitarian material
but also weapons and we've propose today
that the european
facility
be attitude to the tune of some 500
million which is going to allow us to go
further in this
line
countries that in the past were
traditionally neutral sweden for
instance have decided for the very first
time
in the for the first time in decades
they will take an active role in
the support to ukraine we also have
economic support humanitarian support
this will be contingent continued some 2
million refugees have been welcomed
madame vanderlian has referred to this
and i'd like to thank the populations of
the neighboring countries poland hungary
romania
and moldova as well
and obviously france will be playing its
role and i would hope that we will be
able to have the necessary mechanisms of
solidarity that can be used in this
overall approach as of the very outset
we also deployed massive unheard of
sanctions and this was done very quickly
second
fourth six days of conflict they were
marked by european decisions
of these
unprecedented sanctions
we're willing to adopt other sanctions
and all options are on the table
the point of our discussion is to order
is to prepare ourselves for these
sanctions if they were
able to call a halt to the attack and
the aggression and could prepare us also
for
the consequences in the coming weeks and
months
our initial objective is of course a
rapid return to peace
starting with the ceasefire
followed by a rapid withdrawal of
russian troops and that is why keeping
up pressure on russia
and we're also maintaining a very
demanding dialogue
in particular in conjunction with the
german chancellor so the support to
solidarity for ukraine
is what kept us very busy particularly
yesterday
we support ukraine today and we will do
that for as long as the war lasts and we
will be there
for the reconstruction of this
destruction brought about by russia we
will be there to help it to stand up and
stay standing
the message that we've sent out to the
ukrainian population
is that the path to our europe is open
to them their fight for freedom and
democracy for the values that we all
share has demonstrated that ukraine is
indeed a member of our european family
we also want the
applications
made by moldova and georgia as well
be examined in line with our treaty by
the european commission
so that
the acceptability
can be determined
in line with the provisions of our
treaty
the versailles declaration
the agenda that we've been discussing
today
linked to the fact that sovereignty in
europe
which
might have been thought of by some as a
slogan
or a sort of french fantasy
is seen by all today as being
crucial
the sovereignty this is
the strategy of independence has been
there at the very start also the
pandemic we've seen what will have to be
done it's there when
we have to produce
and deliver vaccines for ourselves and
for other countries we've seen it when
we came out of the crisis uh the start
of the recovery when we saw what was
happening as we got to the semi
conductors when we had delegated
production to the other parts of the
world how difficult it was to return to
the manufacturing of cars for instance
and we're seeing
it in the context of this crisis where
we can see
how our food our energy our defense
are all issues of sovereignty we can
cooperate
we want to be open to the world but we
want to choose our partners and not
depend on any that's what we mean by
sovereignty it's not protectionism it's
not a question of closing the door it's
a question of having the possibility of
staying open without being dependent so
the vasa agenda has set out the next few
months work along those lines as regards
defense
we want to be able to define the
investments that we need and several of
us are already at the level of two
percent of gdp invested in defense
others have further efforts to make but
we're going to make coordinated efforts
we're going to identify our needs and
budgetary terms we're going to identify
capabilities that are required we'll
also identify our needs when it comes to
possible new conflicts whether we're
talking about shipping maritime space
and also identify
what we need in order to develop the
european industrial
tissue
if we're going to import more in the way
of hardware from elsewhere then there's
not not much point pursuing this sort of
sovereignty we need to think in terms of
partnerships yes but we have to be able
to decide
to consolidate and to construct
a defense industry with fewer standards
but corresponding to an integrated
market
so the number of decisions that we've
already taken
ago germany in turn decided to make
historic investments
in the country for the country
and denmark made a historic choice
deciding
to
ask the people if they want to come back
to the european security and defense
project you can see that everywhere
around the european continent historic
choices are being made and this is a
major turning point
we need to have the organization so that
we can build this joint
ambition in defense and this is what we
have asked the commission to do so that
by may
uh when we would know that have an
extraordinary meeting of the council
before the
summit in june in the summit meeting in
june we will work up a plan which is
full for uh investment to get our
industries up to the right
capacity and capability level
and then
we've got the question of
of climate strategy we've started
building our own independence getting
out of
fossil energy as a matter of becoming
independent and we know that moving away
from coal was a special punk then we
moved to gas but that's gas that we have
imported and are still importing from
russia
the situation that we're in at the
moment and which we will have tomorrow
means we have to reassess this strategy
and be even more ambitious with our
climate plans
and for that
we will have a
a check on this by late march and see
how we can provide the support for our
populations for president and we're
going to work on this at the commission
with concrete
objectives for prices and for uh and for
refining so that we can guarantee their
mechanisms
which means that we're not
subjected to the contingencies of the
market or speculation of the market in
particular in crisis situations many of
you have already
taken steps to protect
our citizens and companies and we need
to have european choices and in the two
weeks to come we will
do our best so that we can stand up to
the price shock which comes from the
geopolitical
context prices were going up before the
war and they're continuing to increase
because of the war
course we have the sanctions which are
coming in and we must prepare ourselves
so that we are not so sensitive to the
dependency on russia and this is what
we've
scheduled for may for the commission as
the two presidents have pointed out we
have the plan to step out of the
dependency on fossil fuels from russia
so that we can get up by 2027 so that we
are no longer dependent on uh russian uh
gas oil and coal that's by 2027 this
means there has to be new investment new
facilities
so that we can um
support our choices for renewables and
for nuclear energy you can see that
march and may will be very busy
for energy subjects
and there are other issues that we will
have to work together on
to ensure that we are independent and
sovereign there's the food strategy
whether we're talking about wheat or
maize or grain crops in general we know
that ukraine and russia are two huge
markets
and europe has already been upset by the
war on the on the fruit supply market
and this will be even more so
in 12 to 18 months
with the impact on ukraine and crops
there and there will be a major
disturbance to food supplies in
in field feed supplies so we have to
strike a new balance and look at food
production so that we can have
autonomy for our food production and for
protein production and we must reassess
the strategy for africa because the
number of african countries are going to
be hit by famines in the next 12 to 18
months
because of this
[Music]
sovereignty war other commodities
raw materials for rare materials
and i've mentioned the question of
semiconductors the health care i won't
go through the whole list but we have
this agenda we will be going through
this in the months to come with very
concrete proposals for investments which
will make it possible for to have more
sovereign and more independent europe
we will be
encouraging
and we're going to look at the single
market in different sectors
clear and the european uh
the central european bank will be
following its work and will be doing
this very clearly in the current
geopolitical geopolitical context and
will have national investment policies
to protect us from the impact of the war
to fund our solidarity to fund our
resistance to the impact of the war and
to defend our sovereignty but the next
point is that we
need
means of
funding these major strategies funding
from europe and
these are the things i mentioned and
this is why we need to have joint
funding we need to coordinate our
investments and we should do it in a
european context so that we don't see
the financial markets being broken up
and
and different forms of sovereign debt
and this is what we've been
working on as our strategy and we'll be
working on it for the months to come and
here we will have to be
acting together acting swiftly and with
the spirit of responsibility
the ukrainians have given us
an example which is quite unique the
example of courage
we are not waging war
europe is not waging war on russia but
we're supporting
ukraine and we're sanctioning russia but
we must have the courage to make
historic decisions
to see that the defense of democracy and
our values has a cost the choice of
independence has a cost
and sometimes we have to go back on some
of the dogmas that we've been following
for years the different habits and the
ways of organizing things which we had
and i can tell you that the discussions
we had yesterday and today
have
realized this awareness and we can see
there's a real ambition here from the
europeans here in the site to advance in
that direction and i would like to
conclude on that
we started the work yesterday by
extending thanks to some of the
colleagues i would like to say this to
the president of the commission because
here in versailles it's a very historic
site which the french of course love
above all and which we're very proud of
and we see it it's known around the
world but it's a site which is also the
site of diplomatic defeats
it's the site where we lost peace
we were there
with an ambition to
humiliate and divide europe
with the treaty of vexa
and despite
the difficulties we've had here today
with the emotions and
different attitudes we did have a
unanimous
agreement on the fact that the only way
of protecting our continent was through
unity through courage and unity that's
the most important thing
thank you